good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp
1659
object class
ketter
special containment
procedures level three 1659 clearance
staff are limited to interaction in the
field with
scp-1659 instances per the terms of the
nine-mile station protocol all
interaction with
alpha
scp-1659-alpha
scp-1659 beta instances must be
conducted through recognized diplomatic
channels in the department of external
affairs the currently recognized
ambassador to scp-1659
is dr danamir alcanti
due to the widespread nature of scp-1659
containment is focused on suppressing
public knowledge of the true purpose of
activities carried out by scp-1659
instances priority is to be given to
activities with the greatest risk of
resulting in violations of the nine-mile
station protocol in keeping with
protocol requirements any
non-observational research of scp-1659
is prohibited without the express
permission of the department of external
affairs
research staff must update the list of
known
scp-1659 instances and the scp-1659
organizational chart weekly to reflect
current information recruiting
preference for
scp-1659 personnel is to be given to
those with backgrounds in sociology
political science diplomacy
organizational theory and culinary
criticism
description
scp-1659 is a quasi-governmental
organization transcending all known
political boundaries and divisions this
organization is made up of at least 315
449 individuals who possess the inherent
sense that they are part of a large
governing organization known to its
members as directorate k individuals
affected by scp-1659
demonstrate knowledge not only of the
existence of this organization but which
specific sub-unit they belong to and a
detailed sense of their duties to be
carried out as part of scp-1659
interviews with affected subjects
suggest that this knowledge is
spontaneously obtained through unknown
means usually between the ages of 17 to
32 once a subject is affected by
scp-1659
no known means are effective in
eliminating knowledge of directorate k
short of systemic neurological damage or
death individuals from throughout the
world appear to be affected by scp-1659
at random
the organizational structure of
scp-1659 is highly complex and appears
to have no overarching goal or purpose
subunits within
scp-1659 are given titles and ostensible
missions however the work performed by
members of a designated subunit often
has no discernible connection with that
unit's stated purpose foundation
researchers have documented 1
297 subunits to date apart from
directorate case serving as a central
administering entity the relationships
of these subunits to one another is
currently impossible to determine
hierarchies appear to change regularly
and reorganizations of these units
happen frequently
individuals affected by scp-1659
frequently spend significant amounts of
time at seemingly pointless tasks
documented examples include
a retired electrician identifying
himself as a technician attached to the
office of slime mold production
repeatedly spinning a coin on the ground
at a crowded bus stop in toronto canada
three individuals claiming to work for
the inui control bureau traveling
throughout rural southwestern slovakia
counting any observed instances of
muscardinus avalonarius common dormouse
and text messaging the results to a
phone number listed at the japanese
embassy in lima peru
a 15th vinyl division work crew in a
privately owned truck traveling to
traffic intersections in various towns
in jon sang province south korea
cleaning signs related to pedestrian
safety
police chief
bolivia and confirmed scp-1659
subject continually building in his
backyard a crude antenna structure four
meters in height out of tin foil
disassembling it and reassembling it a
self-described official meeting of the
people's governing board of gallbladder
health consisting of a spontaneous
gathering of 28 individuals in a remote
region of the mojave desert in
california united states culminating in
the detonation of an explosive device
estimated to be equivalent to 500
kilograms of tnt
individuals affected by
scp-1659 are not compelled in any
discernible manner to perform their
assigned duties however subjects are
almost always highly motivated to carry
out tasks assigned by
scp-1659 and affected individuals
display behavioral traits and attitudes
commonly associated with organizations
displaying high levels of morale and
team cohesion
while observed activity of
scp-1659 subjects at the individual
level appears to have no logical purpose
broader contextual analysis has revealed
that scp-1659
exhibits a profound ability to affect
world commodities market fluctuations
cultural trends particularly those
related to food real estate development
movement of refugee populations and to a
limited extent deployment of military
assets
scp-1659 is believed to achieve this
through a combination of the sum total
of the tasks its subjects carry out its
ownership stake in a collection of
strategic private firms and its
placement of subjects in posts at all
levels of government in most cases
influence exercised by
scp-1659 is subtle and does not deviate
significantly from general societal
expectations though this is theorized to
be partially attributable to
scp-1659's agreement to abide by the
nine-mile station protocol an exception
appears to be trends in fine dining and
culinary technology upon which
scp-1659 has exercised profound effects
many world-renowned restaurants are
either owned or financed by scp-1659
including
in paris france and
in osaka japan and
in catalonia spain
subjects affected by
scp-1659 are present throughout the
world and generally fall into three
observed categories
scp-1659 alpha
these individuals occupy leadership
positions within scp-1659
analogous to agency directors minor
political leaders and other high-ranking
officials approximately two percent of
scp-1659
are classed in this manner members of
directorate k itself believed to be the
central authority on scp-1659
are part of this group and are believed
to number between 100 to 120 individuals
at present
scp-1659
beta
an estimated 15 percent of
scp-1659 instances belong to this class
these individuals tend to be tasked with
duties resembling those of a mid-level
official and are usually supervisory or
quasi-independent in nature many
individuals in this group hold positions
of authority in established governments
at all levels throughout the world
former prime minister of gambia before
being removed by foundation operatives
in the wake of incident 1659-a
m-i-k-e is believed to have been one of
these individuals
scp-1659 gamma
the vast majority of
scp-1659 fall under this classification
these individuals perform tasks
associated with various sub-units of
scp-1659
and are thus the most likely to come to
the attention of foundation assets while
scp-1659 gamma instances are drawn from
a wide array of sources a high
proportion of these individuals are
transients inmates at penal or mental
health institutions or others that
traditionally live outside mainstream
society
the ultimate strategic aims or goals of
scp-1659
if any exists are unknown at this time
addendum
1659 a
summary of nine mile station protocol
foundation researchers discovered
scp-1659
in 1983 after an investigation into
reports of 17 unaffiliated individuals
chasing stray dogs through the streets
of budapest hungary with brooms mops and
various cleaning implements these
reports coincided with a soviet union
organized economic conference occurring
in the city at the same time
from 1983 to 1997
field research was conducted through
standard clandestine means yielding
information suggesting that the scope of
scp-1659
and its potential effects on established
society rendered it inherently
uncontainable
scp-1659 was accordingly classified
ketter and assigned slot 14 on the
prioritized threat register given the
nature of scp-1659
research director franz h ambrose
attempted to establish formal diplomatic
relations with scp-1659
on september 1st 1998 a letter was
received at the address established by
dr ambrose for official contacts
purporting to be from the directorate k
null consulate the letter stated that
scp-1659's acceptance of an invitation
to discuss formal relations between it
and the foundation and a summit was
scheduled for later that year
on december 18 1998 dr ambrose and a
foundation negotiations team arrived at
the abandoned settlement of nine-mile
station california united states per
instructions from scp-1659
the reason stated for the location being
we're thinking of building a restaurant
here and met with miss valentina laconi
nscp 1659 subject documented by
researchers as being a bicycle mechanic
residing in scampia italy miss laconi
presented herself as null consulate
charge a domitian for foundation affairs
and was the only 1659 subject present
miss laconi proved extensively
knowledgeable in the practices of
international diplomacy and demonstrated
her position within scp-1659
by ordering several
scp-1659 subunits in specified locations
to perform tasks requested by the
foundation delegation over the next few
days the foundation delegation and miss
laconi discussed terms for the voluntary
entry of scp-1659
into containment agreement was reached
on december 22nd 1998 and was formally
ratified soon afterward as the nine mile
station protocol by overwatch command
and directorate k itself which delivered
its copy of the protocol signed by 19
code-named individuals via
burrow-mounted messenger to a
pre-designated foundation facility in
guadalajara mexico
stated goals of the signatory parties
the preamble to the nine-mile station
protocol states that the foundations and
scp-1659's mutual desire for preserving
a rational consensus reality for human
civilization while stating that the aims
of the foundation and
scp-1659 are different a commonality of
purpose sufficient for a formal
organized agreement is cited as the
basis for the protocol
requirements on scp-1659
under the protocol
scp-1659 is not to engage in any
activity that may alert any individuals
or organizations not under its influence
to its existence
scp-1659 is not to engage in any
activity causing extensive property
damage or loss of life except in
predefined circumstances of self-defense
which must promptly be reported to
foundation personnel
scp-1659 must limit its total number of
affected individuals to less than 0.1
percent of the estimated world
population at any given time
scp-1659
may not designate foundation personnel
as members of its organization
requirements on the foundation
foundation researchers are permitted to
observe and document all activities
conducted by
scp-1659 gamma individuals foundation
researchers are not permitted to
interfere with such activities unless a
breach of protocol requirements is
reasonably judged to be imminent
foundation staff may transport
scp-1659 affected individuals to
foundation facilities for examination
and interview subject to permission of
the null consulate and in accordance
with directorate k guidelines no fewer
than 30 individuals per annum are to be
made available to the foundation for
this purpose
the foundation may not harm coerce
intimidate or otherwise interfere unduly
with any
scp-1659 subject unless self-defense
expectations are present
requirements on both signatories
the provisions of the nine-mile station
protocol must be reviewed by a
delegation from both signatories at a
tri-annual conference located in neutral
territory amendments may be made to the
protocols subject to approval by both
signatories
neither signatory may be required to
reveal information regarding total
strategic and tactical assets personnel
levels or high-level policy to the other
as of the time of this report no
violations of the nine-mile station
protocol by scp-1659
have been observed
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
givios the hollow
zazzapan
jordan c wilde
lamke
dr briggs
tailored
printers perpetually confused meet mac
pilot
cignar
kylie lacks empathy
alitreon
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate the klein
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio demnatus
the morrigan
and james saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you